The DNA will get you every time.
It's how the suspect in the mid-November
stabbing deaths of four Idaho
students was finally tracked down
and arrested.
That's what we learned
with the affidavit of probable
cause was unsealed in Idaho court
this week.
Investigators had found a leather knife
sheath on the bed of one of the victims.
They found a DNA sample
on the button of the sheath.
This and the cell phone records
tracing his whereabouts capped
the many weeks
long investigation
that included narrowing down which white
Hyundai Elantra
had been captured
on videos
in the neighborhood of the house
where the killings took place.
A Washington State University officer
then located
a 2015 white Hyundai Elantra
in an apartment complex parking lot.
The owner's
driver's license, information
and photograph were consistent
with a surviving roommate's
description of the mass suspect's
height and build and bushy eyebrows.
Additionally, five days
after the murders,
the suspect had obtained
a new license plate for his car.
The car was located at the suspect's
family residence in Albright's
Mill, Pennsylvania.
CNN has reported
he was under surveillance
and he was seen cleaning his car inside
and out using surgical gloves.
And depositing trash in the wee hours
in a neighbor's garbage can.
On December
27, Pennsylvania law enforcement
discovered that trash
and sent it to the Idaho State
Lab for DNA testing.
The very next day,
the lab was able to match a DNA profile
obtained from the trash
as all
but assured
as being from the biological father
to a person
whose DNA was found on the knife sheath
as the document states.
At least 99.9998% of the male population
would be expected to be excluded
from the possibility
of being the suspect's biological father.
Joining me now is Sissy Moore,
head of
Genetic Genealogy
Services for Paraben Nano Labs
Law Enforcement Unit,
which is made more than 200 successful
identifications of violent criminals.
She's not worked the Idaho case.
She stars in the documentary series
The Genetic Detective,
now streaming on ABC.
And she is also
has worked
on all ten seasons of the PBS
television documentary series
Finding Your Roots
with Henry Louis Gates, JR.
Thank you for being here.
What does this mean?
Single source of male DNA,
which I'm reading from the affidavit.
It means there were no other DNA
detected on that.
Meaning sometimes you can have a mixture.
You can have multiple people's DNA.
You want to have single source DNA,
if at all possible,
because that really just ties
that one person to that item.
Now, it was likely that
this was touch DNA.
Certainly it's possible there was blood.
They didn't tell us what type of DNA,
but most likely it was touch DNA.
And that would typically be just
a few skin cells.
This might have been
a very small amount of DNA,
but because of today's
technological advances,
we can detect even the
tiniest bit of DNA.
How reliable is touch DNA
if it is skin
cells in comparison to, say, blood?
It's a great question.
It is more transferable.
So of course,
you would like to have blood.
You would like to have semen or saliva.
And they might
you know,
they haven't shown all their cards.
We don't know all that they have,
but touch DNA
now that we can use it
because of the sensitivity
of our equipment.
It also means
you have to be more cautious
about using DNA as your only evidence.
So it's a really positive thing
that they clearly have other evidence.
This is just one piece of it.
We have seen
DNA touch, DNA transfer in other cases.
Of course,
it's fairly rare,
but it is something that you
have to be aware of.
And make sure
that there are other aspects of the case
also pointing at the same person.
Good news.
I guess
it's hard
to commit murder
without leaving something behind.
That's right.
Yeah. I've been saying this for weeks.
That type of violent, intimate crime,
it is virtually impossible
not to leave something behind.
Even if you are a criminology
PhD student.
So I am not at all surprised
they were able to find something.
Even if he tried hard
not to leave something, you still would.
And that is great news
because what it means
is that
anyone who perpetrates
this type of crime in the future
should be aware
that they will be identified.
They will be caught.
There really is no reason
that we should see a serial killer,
serial rapist moving forward.
This guy, you know,
potentially could have become a Ted Bundy
or even a Zodiac
not identified 50 years later,
but because of the DNA technology,
the advances that we're seeing,
both in investigative genetic genealogy
and the ability
to use tiny amounts of DNA,
we can identify someone,
whether they are in the law
enforcement database or not.
CC the cases that you have cracked
for which you have become
famous are the cases that necessitate
you putting together
with in connection with a private lab,
a very complicated family
history, family tree
and tracing back cousins and generations.
That doesn't seem to be
what took place here.
Well, I don't think we can reach that
conclusion yet.
Investigative genetic genealogy is simply
a tip. It's a lead generator.
It should never be used as evidence.
Against a suspect.
And so it is proper
that it would have been left
out of the affidavit, in my opinion,
because it should not form
the basis of an arrest warrant.
And so even though they didn't
put it in there,
I don't think we can rule it out.
We don't know whether it was
what initially identified him
as a person of interest.
And then they looked more closely
at that
tip about the car,
or it could have gone the other way
where they identified him
through that tip about the car.
And at the same time,
they were working on
the genetic genealogy
and may have built his family
tree to see if it was consistent
with what they were seeing.
I have done that in some cases,
if there are persons of interest.
You can very quickly
rule them out or potentially not.
Be able to exclude them,
which is what would have happened
in this case.
Maybe they could have connected him
to one or more of those matches,
maybe a second, third, fourth cousin
and said, look,
you know,
this is somebody
who is a strong person of interest.
So I think there's still a lot
for us to learn on what happened here.
I do think it is highly likely
that an advanced private outside lab
was used, at least somehow in this case.
You know, we've all been hearing
whispers of this.
There's been lots of leaks
that investigative
genetic genealogy was used.
So I do think that they were trying to or
in the process of doing so.
And you make a great point.
They, of course, don't have to put
in this affidavit of probable cause.
They the prosecutors, all that they have.
See, Seymour.
That was tremendous.
I thank you, as always.